throughout the 20th century what was the
relationship between communism
and
um Jews in the Soviet Union
what in terms of anti-Semitism the ups
and downs of anti-Semitism it seems like
it lessened it was lesser and greater in
different parts of the 20th century well
it's it's the kind of thing where
um if something was bad it's there's
this Russian rhyme uh you could like
yesterday
like if there's if there's no water in
the sink who drank it all the Jews
um so if something goes wrong there's
there's just a convenient historical
scapegoat it's the Jew's fault so this
is something that's towards the end of
his life very much and this was after
World War II Stalin was getting ready
for another kind of series of programs
there all these Jews were getting kicked
out of their jobs uh Jewish doctors were
getting sent to the Far East instead of
being in cities uh the newspaper started
talking about uh Cosmopolitan rootless
cosmopolitans which was a term the Nazis
also used to kind of uh regard Jews as
others or as aliens and this was going
to be and and they were very clever
about it uh in Pravda they would and I
talk about this and then the white pill
improved that there were articles that
it uh led us to the editor they were
like you know things are getting so
anti-semitic we really should round up
all the Jews and send them elsewhere for
their own safety so they were kind of
setting the the ground rules or the the
or the basis to have this sort of uh
program come back but uh spoiler alert
um Stalin dies and immediately
um all this gets reversed and the new
Administration
um rehabilitates the doctors who are
accused of trying to hurt him and all
this other sort of thing
what is it about the scapegoats in
society are we always going to be
looking for scapegoats what do you learn
from Human Nature that this seems to
keep happening I think because there's a
book called The nurture assumption
and I discussed this in the new right
and what the author learned
is that humans Define themselves by
opposition
so if you have a group of people and
it's kids and adults the kids will see
themselves as kids because we're as
opposed to adults if the adults leave
the kids see themselves as boys and
girls because I'm not a girl I'm a boy
I'm not a boy I'm a girl so they divide
so this idea which is very Lefty idea
that human beings naturally all get
along is not accurate and the best
example of this is look after 9 11. look
where there's a war nothing unites the
popular it's not like when times are
thriving that everyone's all working
together when things are bad and there's
an enemy you know it's it's the Japanese
of Pearl Harbor it's Al Qaeda that's
when everyone really comes together
because now we have someone to be
against so there will always be
someone has to be the out group and we
have to be the end group as opposed to
them
but there's a viciousness to the actions
you take to the uh towards the out group
that that varies throughout his yes some
like the degree of viciousness can cross
the line towards like atrocities towards
genocide right and that's that's the
question of in
why does this sometimes do that why does
it sometimes cross into genocide I
understand it's a useful thing to have
the other to blame in this world
especially when times are rough but why
does that sometimes
lead to a sort of action that says I'm
going to murder well I'm going to
torture together the question really is
why sometimes it doesn't right and one
of the things I learned when I was doing
the new right is a lot of the uh Nazis
using that term loosely speaking
neo-nazis they make the point they're
like oh when the Holocaust happened it
really wasn't that big of a deal and
that only became a big deal in the
decades later and this just shows the
power of Jewish influence and I'm like
this to me is a great thing it's a great
thing that we sat down
pretty recently historically and we're
like wait a minute guys when we have a
war or we have Conquest you don't have
to just start killing everyone like this
is something that's bad and wrong and
and certainly in the last 60 years 70
years this is something that people have
come to take for granted but that wasn't
the case before it would always be or
not always but often if you conquer you
just go wild and just start slaughtering
massive people
um it's um who's the guy from um Harvard
um and he Stephen pink Steven Pinker I'm
sorry I forgot his name so he just talks
about like you know we know this is one
of the reasons also why there was so
much skepticism when the Holocaust
started because this was regarded as
something that was barbaric this is from
the Middle Ages from the Biblical times
we don't do this anymore we're civilized
now so genocide is
historically the norm I think it's also
harder to pull it off emotionally when
you have the visuals and when you have
the audio and when you have the voices
of the people being slaughtered we don't
know you know if this was 2000 years ago
and people you know in the Bible they go
kill this group go kill that group we
don't have their names we don't have the
visuals we have anything but when you
see someone being like you know they're
uh there's a book about I think the
Rwandan Genocide and the title is we
regret to inform you that tomorrow we
will be executed with all of our
families like a telegram and like when
you get a telegram like this it's very
different than reading some history book
about you know the Assyrians kill the
Phoenicians it's like I don't know who
this is I don't know who that is right
so I think this is something that has
changed uh very recently there was this
kind of interesting moment just that
speaks to the way technology has
liberated people from violence
um kristallnacht which was a moment in
uh the lead up to the Holocaust were
basically you know with Hitler's
blessing you had a nationwide burning of
Jewish businesses synagogues burnt down
and Kaiser Wilhelm uh you know the
Kaiser he said for the first time my
life I'm embarrassed to be a German but
that was a moment where worldwide even
plenty of people who did not think very
highly of Jewish people were like
this is
the rap this is a complete nightmare but
200 years ago 100 years ago maybe not
literally a crystal knocked but there's
an out group and we hate them and we're
gonna kill them and it's fine and you
think it's even more difficult now with
the internet yeah that kind of thing
yeah I'm not now more difficult this
mean doesn't happen or it can't happen
I'm not saying that at all but I'm
saying
the we know a lot about what's going on
in North Korea you know probably the
most secretive country on Earth there's
a lot of atrocities in Eritrea uh which
is kind of known so I think it also it's
also
like if you think about it if you're how
many years ago 300 years ago you only
know the people in your village and
they're all probably going to look like
you so on and so forth whereas now if
I'm on social media and there's someone
from any country and maybe their picture
looks a little different they use the
same anime picture as somebody else but
they're putting forth their ideas
you do see the humanity in them and you
do see a sense of familiarity and a
familial bond with them and when you
hear about these things you know when I
again like I did when I did dear reader
no one
and I was on Al-Qaeda and I was on Alex
Jones no one pushed back about like oh
the North Koreans they were all like
this is horrible if I had a magic wand
I'd give them food I wouldn't have them
live in fear uh and this is something
that I don't think was the case a couple
hundred years ago